beyond the horizon of these warm waters
lapping the shore of zazas tragedy is
playing out and thyme and tide are
bringing the bodies of its victims to
these tourist beaches more than 70
migrants drowned last month when their
inflatable raft sank in rough weather
the director of the Red Crescent who
helped pull them out of the water told
me the corpses were floating in from
every direction
episodes episode la saving these people
and even returning them to a prison in
Libya is better than letting them die
like that in huge numbers young people
pregnant women and babies is the
northern European countries that'd be a
heavy responsibility it's a crime this
garbage tip outside zazas is where the
dead bodies used to be dumped the Red
Crescent has now reburied them nearby
but these graves share the same ground
as a city's rubbish we spoke to a young
man who nearly ended up here himself
we left Libya in small boats into the
deep sea the boat started to shake until
it's capsized in that moment I regret
what I did and now every time I remember
what happened I feel sick
Muhammad is taking refuge at the Red
Crescent center outside zazas other
survivors like him are still struggling
to cope with the terror they endured
wondering if they ever dare to go
through it all again to reach Europe a
new cemetery is being built here it
already contains the bodies of 71 people
that were washed ashore on the city
beaches last month each of these graves
have been numbered in a DNA sample has
been taken from each one of the victims
the record of those is being held at the
local hospital already the director of
the Red Crescent is receiving inquiries
from all over the sahel region and even
from Morocco about who might be lying
here these waters are meant to be a
source of fun and pleasure but the death
toll is rising all the time and that's
reality that's
this Beach David chata al-jazeera zazas